[Musique]
beaucoup d'art en chimie avec mayonnaise
spiri peary jeu 6 de boeuf et bâtonnets
de mozzarella dans une panure o pango
ce six maisons ou jalapenos et fromages
avec panure de cumin et de chine
on peut dire que le pogo à des manières
bien élégante d'apparaître sur les menus
tout va bien ensemble on peut vous y a
pas de limite on peut le faire au roman
a les crocs mears on peut le faire au
bout des mains ou restera loubat le chef
stéphane giguère a créé un logo qui fait
voyager
ceux-ci site aliens à la patate douce
coriandre cumin écurie avec un soft de
mozzarella enrobé d'une pâte à la cage
aux assassins goûteux ça ça y est la
femme la part neuf cas c'est christiane
morts mais christian le pogo et rendu si
populaire qu'il amène sa semaine ici à
drummondville pour le chef mathieu
gauthier organisateur de l'événement cet
engouement n'a rien d'étonnant je pense
que c'est quelque chose de super simple
qui pas trop intellectuel c'est comme ça
reste d'astrid foule ça reste quelque
chose qui se mangent sur le pouce
facteur c'est facile approche pour la
clientèle puis en plus de ça donne tout
et c'est aussi compliqué pour les chefs
et ce n'est pas l'inspiration qui manque
ici on cuisine ne pas gober tarrier
c'est l'école qui ont acheté des
concombres des champs de la ferme des
armes ici au marché
et puis on les a faites mariner bien sûr
une pâte de maïs comme en auto salade de
pomme radis avec un l'abonné maison à la
betterave qu'un petit pas de
une pomme et canneberges je pense que
tous les goûts sont permis les goûts
sont dans la nature mais on s'appelle
surprise parce que ça reste quand même
une part qui cache quelque chose
cette pente qui cache quelque chose
vient du texas
elle aurait été inventée lors d'une
foire de campagne dans les années 40
on l'appelait kong dong
une fois traversé la frontière elle a
pris le nom de sa marque de commerce
pogo
n'importe comment n'importe où n'importe
quand
pauvre si c'est toi écrit sur un bâton
c'est pas un vrai pot go dans ce casse
croûte de montréal tout est fait maison
on a créé un pogo traditionnelle avec
des ingrédients frais seulement on aime
le casse tête
on aime vraiment ça puis on aime
vraiment faire tout maisons cités comme
un challenge il
ok on va prendre l'associé sont mal à
faire maison on va faire la partie qui
sait ce qu'est ce qu'on fait on est
connu pour ça on commence notre patte
la recette est simple farine de blé
farine de maïs sucre sel poudre à pâte
mais et pour mélange bien
pas très compliqué du tout istres
mélange là on à le faire reposer facile
recouvert dans le frigo
environ une demi heure
[Musique]
soit
ça c'est la mienne et je vais essayer de
faire mieux et enfiler exact dans ton
dos stresseurs tueur à gages je t'engage
on trempe simplement la saucisse dans la
g
pis si tôt pour moi inventer puis il
suffit d'offrir le pogo dans une huile
végétale pendant 5 à 7 minutes jusqu'à
ce que la pâte soit bien doré et
déguster
qu'il soit classé qui aurait inventé les
pogo sont de plus en plus apprécié je
pense c'est vraiment c'est réconfortant
c'est frais t-il le goût salé farine
demain samedi peu sucré il ya toujours
dans la porte un petit peu de sucre donc
sucré salé puis après la fameuse ou
tahar besbes et l'acidité qui vient
couper la friture c'est quand même c'est
parfait oui c'est bon un pabx ou
standard mais découvrir d'un groupe à
gauche passe 45 la vallasse et des
nouveaux goûts à la pâtisserie créations
sucrées josée bilodeau créer des pogos
qui sortent de l'ordinaire
nous on fait les gaufres maison donc on
les femmes seraient plus sur le long et
on met de la crème glacée en 2 go qui
sont bien sûr avec un bâton et puis
ensuite on tremble ça dans un chocolat
30 âge c'est lui qui préférait puis en
mai dernier sur que vous préférez ça
fait des biscuits oreo davies dc 10
d'uta payet de chacun heures d'écart à
miel des choses comme ça
vous
c'est sûr que c'est différent ouais mais
ce n'est pas cette envie de créer une
salle et que j'aime bien chaud sur canal
le pogo sucre et je trouve que c'est
l'idéal parce que ça vient après hugo
boss allez donc la petite touche de
sucre et à la fin c'est toujours bien
comme ça peut être tellement
personnalisés c'est parti en collation
ou en plat de résistance
on peut dire que le pogo a maintenant
bien meilleure réputation
[Musique]